be kind to yourself please that was my  answer in exact five words of my best  business advice why is this important a  if you're not in the Discord you're  making a massive mistake the Discord is  linked in my bio and profile right now  please come and join and if it's your  first time first comment when you get in  there say first time please but what is  this about the number one reason that I  am successful in business is because I'm  kind to myself so many of you  entrepreneurs aspiring entrepreneurs  aspiring managers and leaders just beat  yourself up for what you suck at a  misstep if it's not going well for a day  a week a month a year being kind to  yourself is the number one way to be  happy and successful not only in  business but in parenting in in other  aspects of Our Lives it's the number one  game being kind to yourself needs to be  your goal for 2023 I promise